Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in the chapters of alus bathing.
This is not just any bathing. This of
course is religious bathing. It's one of
the great rights of Islam.
And as a matter of fact, the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam in some
wordings of the narration of Gibl
listed it amongst the pillars of Islam.
This is one of the most
differentiating features and one of
the great hallmarks
that set the believer aside from the
disbeliever.
We mentioned two so far. The first was
hurily
the expulsion of sperm or semen and
the second which was intercourse. We
have three more to go. Number three is
when a person becomes Muslim when they
enter into Islam
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
made it one of the rights of this great
moment of entering into Islam
as bathing
[Silence]
So when he accepted Islam,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
commanded him to bathe and to use water
in sidd. Do we know what sidar is?
[Arabic recitation]
grows in the desert and it has leaves.
They kind of look lemon leaves,
a lemon tree, right? And it has
cleaning properties. So this is what
they used to use for soap. Acid was used
for soap. to get something that's
honory out, you know, a difficult stain
or something, they would use dirt and
they would also mix into the water a
cider. So they would take these leaves
of a cider and they would
use it to clean the way that we
use soap today. And this is also the
sunnah to use a
in bathing the dead
as the prophet sallall.aii wasallam also
commanded. So whenever you see the use
of acidiv in narrations
with respect to
bathing, this is the purpose for it. And
sid is a notorious tree for not having
any fruit and having thorns.
But one of the trees of paradise is
what?
Right.
So, one of the most fruitless trees
becomes full of fruits in paradise.
The fourth instance
and in other narrations, the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
would command people that accepted Islam
new to trim their nails, to trim their
hair, to trim their mustache if it is
overgrown.
,
and this is considered kind of a
new beginning when a person goes
to.
So all of this is part of the sunnah
along with bathing.
The fourth is
after a woman's cycle is completed, it's
over, or at the end of postpartum
bleeding, which is after childbirth,
which will never be any longer than 40
days ever. Even if it continues
physically, after 40 days, it's no
longer nest.
After these two instances,
the woman must bathe in order to be
back in a state of spiritual purity.
Either
[Silence]
so the prophet Sam
told Fatima
if your cycle
begins then leave off praying. Don't
pray, stop praying and then if it
completes and concludes then bathe and
then pray. And this is something well
known amongst the Muslim. It is
something that is agreed upon amongst
all of the scholars in the Muslim that a
woman must bathe at the end of her cycle
at the end of her postpartum in order to
begin prayer again. And bathing after
one cycle after postpartum is a more
deep bathing than just Geneva
because
a woman and a man are not required to
take out the braids in their hair for
bathing from Geneva.
They are h a woman however is obligated
to take her braids out at least
at the end of her cycle or postpartum
when she bathes.
The fifth and final instance in which
bathing is obligatory is the day of jum.
Now notice the wording here
the day of jum.
You notice the wording. It is not for
per se. It's the day of J. This is an
important distinction
as we will read in the narration.
This is upon everyone whether a person
is traveling or not, whether a person is
male or female, whether a person is ill
or or or well, if they're able to bathe.
[Silence]
had. Wasam.
Here we have a narration on the
authority of
in which the messenger of Allah
wasallam said and the narration is in
both Bkari and Muslim
the
he says bathing for Jum or bathing on
Jum is an obligation that is binding
upon every
person of pubescent age
meaning anyone over the age of puberty
is obligated to bathe on the day of J.
Is going to attending Jum obligatory
upon everyone of the age of puberty.
What's the answer? No. There's people
who are traveling. There's people who
are ill. There's people females in
general,
slaves, right? There's a number of
conditions for to be obligatory.
However, the wording of the narration
articulates that bathing is for the day
of J and not necessarily for the salah
of J. Now
many of the scholars
have interpreted this narration to be to
mean that it is
a sunnah that is to be widespread as
if it is binding
and that binding here is to mean that it
is highly recommended
and they use as an evidence for this
narration. ions that indicate that
is still valid even if the person has
not bathed. I'll give you an example
and his
was on the Omar was the Khalifa for how
many years?
11 years. 11 years is a long time. But
not only that, but he became the Khalifa
two years and change after the prophet's
death. So
if we think about who was in the crowd
during his kha,
if we were to put a percentage on it,
what percentage of the crowd in Medina
were companions
in those 11 years, very early? Probably
90% maybe 85%, right? A a huge majority.
We have major companions there. So the
things that Omar says on the meimar are
highly important because the other
companions are listening
and if we have no disagreement from any
of these companions this means that it
is something that everyone there is
agreeing upon.
So Omar is on the he's given the
walks in
and Omar
points him out and speaks to him while
he's on the and presses him why he's
late.
Person must be in the masid before the
imam gets on the mim.
And so he presses him why he's late in
front of everyone. Yes. In front of
everyone. This is a leader of the
Muslim. Why are you late?
He said, "I came as soon as I could. I
didn't even make." And Omar said,
"On top of you being late, you also
didn't make."
So what do we understand from this
exchange? If
was invalid without
then he would have told him if was
unaware he would have told him go back
and makeul your salah is not going to be
valid without it correct right but he
didn't and so the point here of the
narration is there's a number of
narrations this that
articulate that
the validity of J meaning it being valid
not it being rewarding that's a
different thing we're talking about bare
minimum valid you are not required to
make it again
is not built upon
salah is built upon we understand
that but does that make
not an obligation no
this is a separate thing this is for the
day of Jum and this is for the reward of
Jum. So we keep the narration of the
prophet as it is and we say what he
said. He says
is an obligation. Who am I to say? Well,
it's not really an obligation. It's
actually something that is preferred. I
wouldn't want to be the guy to say that
we keep his words as they are as he
intended them to be. So if we are asked
what is the ruling on we say exactly
what he said.
Foreham.